Russia's foreign minister Sergey lavrov
is in South Africa for talks he's
meeting with the foreign minister naledi
Pandora in Pretoria last week South
Africa's military announced plans to
hold joint military exercises off its
coasts with China and Russia South
Africa is among the countries that I've
seen from voting in the United Nations
to condemned to condemn rather moscow's
annexations of Ukrainian regions last
year
we are all in favor in favor of peaceful
resolution of disputes and uh will be
will be always ready to discuss
negotiated solution to any conflict on
Earth in September President zielinski
signed a degree prohibiting
all Ukrainian officials to negotiate on
anything with the Russian Federation so
I believe it is absolutely obvious as
regards to the origin of the problem of
lack of negotiations
are sincere wish that the conflict
currently between Russia and Ukraine
will soon be brought to a peaceful end
through diplomacy and negotiation as we
believe this is the desire of all of us
in the globe live to Al jazeera's family
who is in Pretoria Forest tell us more
about what's been said family there and
and how significant this visit to South
Africa is
for the Russian foreign minister
well it was a very very short opening
remarks from both foreign Ministers of
South Africa and Russia but even within
that time they immediately addressed the
issue of Ukraine and Russia's role in
that and that as we heard therefore Mr
lavrov that Russia was willing to
negotiate at least come to a negotiate
settlement with Ukraine and he'd also
added that however Western colleagues
any attempt that they had made for
negotiations had certainly not improved
the situation and essentially South
Africa is a foreign minister naledi
Pondo basically reiterating the sort of
sentiment in that negotiation and
diplomacy is key and that there should
be alternative institutional mechanisms
these should be created to support a
Global Peace and security and in that
regard emphasize the role of brics that
block of countries Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa and this is
essentially where the issue of
geopolitics relations come into play and
an alternative to the dominance of
Western countries where Russia has now
for some time being increasingly
isolated and critics so an analyst would
perhaps say that the second trip in just
about nine months to Africa for the
Russian foreign minister is really about
trying to cement African relations
looking for allies in a place uh where
Russia is increasingly isolated and
perhaps wants to validate its position
in Ukraine amongst its own people saying
that we do have allies we do have
friends and we know that looking back at
U.N resolutions or attempts at that in
the past that less than half of the 54
African nations has had voted or had
wanted to vote in favor of um condemning
Russia's actions in Ukraine 17 of those
African countries that in fact abstained
entirely including South Africa South
Africa has faced some criticism around
its really relationship with Russia and
perhaps wanting to having abstained from
those U.N resolutions or at least voting
and for example from opposition parties
here in South Africa and also the
Ukrainian president zielinski saying
that
um abstaining and having any not having
anything to say is basically trying to
abstain between life and death and this
wasn't a principal position and at this
point we've got Russia saying the exact
opposite it appreciates what it calls a
principled position by South Africa so
while these two countries have said that
this is about bilateral talks we know
very much it's about Russia wanting to
potentially change the playing field
cement these relationships in Africa at
a time when it's facing increasing
isolation in the west thank you for that
family demila live there in Pretoria